（ドアの開ける音）
（刀を持つ音）
（刀の金属音）
（笑顔）
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁ
でへへへへ
一回、さし、さしさし
ダメ、ダメ、ダメ
お願い、ちょちょちょ
先っぽだけ
ダメです。ダメ
はい。というわけで、
いよいよ、夏の季節本番ということで、
夏といえば、なんですか？
海。
そして、夏といえば、あの果物。
なんでしょう？
スイカ。
大正解！
とういうわけで、今日は
スイカ割りをしていこうと思います！
一般的、スイカ割りというのは
こう、目を隠してぐるぐる回って
ヨロヨロっとして、
スイカ叩きに行くんですけども、
ヴゥ
うふふふふふ
何？
生ぬるい。
というわけで、今日は
うぉぉ
今日はスイカ割りをただするんじゃなくて、
チョロいっすね。
回転数が。
回転数が全然、少ないんですけども
ま、僕ぐらいになると
多少の回転数なんか関係なくなってくるんで
例えば、何回か普通は10回転とかじゃない？
そんな思う？
やるときは。
10回転でいいの？
１００でしょ。
いやいやいやいや、一万いこうや。
ね、一万って
マジで本当に思っている以上にやばいよ。
（無言）
（♪）
まずは、お試しで1,000回。
1000回転してバシッと決めます。
まず、軽い気持ちで
1000回転してから
完璧な俺の動きと
指示で
綺麗に
スイカ叩き割ってやろうと思います。
▲☆＝￥！
スイカを▲☆＝￥！＞♂×＆あじゃじゃーす。
では、いこう！
（♪）
んふふふふふ
えっどう？
まぬけな顔になってるね。
失礼極まりない。
待て待て
剣剣剣
ねぇ、痛いのやめてよ！
大丈夫、大丈夫。
ねぇゴメン、マサキ。ホント、ホント、ホント。
ねぇ、ホント、ホント、ホント。
あおぉぉぉ！
逆逆
ドコドコドコ？
これ、どこ？
（シャッターに当たる音）
では、1000回転していきたいと思います。
声出していこう〜
おぃ〜
ハァ〜？！？！？
（笑い声）
声出していこう〜
うい〜！
いきます！
ねぇ
声だそう？
共有しようよ。
だいすけに話しかけないで。
それ、だいすけだから
（早送り）
うわぁぁぁぁ！
ドコドコドコ？
落ち着き、落ち着き、落ち着き、落ち着き
緊急事態、緊急事態
どこどこ？　誰誰？
どこ？
マサキ？
なんかエンディングみたいになっちゃった。
（早送り）
あぁ、▲☆＝￥！ももも、マサキ、マサキ、マサキ
よし、ちょっとちょっと
やばい。
これ止まったら意味ないよ？
（ヴィブラスラップの音）
いくぞー！
（早送り）
よっしゃ、２００
これ思ったんだけどさぁ
最後に目隠しすればよくね？
ちょっとタンマ。
タンマしたらもう。。。
あ、そうだ。
あ、じゃあ、あの、
ちょっと目隠ししながらだと本当に危ないので、
スイカ割りする前に、
ケガしちゃうと、
もったいないので、
目隠しせず、
1000回転したあとに、
目隠しして、
スイカ割りします。
（早送り）
３００！
うぇぇぇぇぇ
ゴホッコホッ
（早送り）
これ以上やると、ヴォォォォエェ
５００回以内にしましょう。
（早送り）
はい、スタート！
どこ？
もうちょいねぇ、右に体を
体を右に
（シャッターに当たる音）
若干、右により
あ、痛！
ヴォォォォエェ
右よって！
右に向いて
進まないでストップ！
体を右に向けて！
二歩下がって。
はい。
進まないで。
あっ
（笑い声）
そこだ！
これか！
カッ！
はぁ　はぁ
やばいって、汗もやばいもん。
マジ、やばい　マジ、やばい
やるよ。普通に。
（スイカの切れる音）
おぉ！
おぉ、凄い！
というわけで、
すみません。
多分、1,000回行ってたら死んでたね。
スイカ割りの
回転数の限界は多分、
400ぐらいです。
400超えてからはちょっとは
本当に危機を感じたので、
みんな、スイカ割りするときは。。。
10回ぐらいにしときな！